as britain comes to terms with the loss
of queen elizabeth ii
she was just
fabulous absolutely fabulous
and the arrival of king charles iii the
economists editor-in-chief zanny minton
bedos and britain correspondent
catherine nixie
discuss what the queen's death means for
britain
and the future of the british monarchy
[Music]
in one sense the reaction is wholly
unsurprising she was britain's oldest
longest reigning monarch she appeared on
more currencies than any living person
you couldn't
send a letter without seeing her face
and she's woven into the fabric of
british life but she was also in a way
very domestic we were kind of very
you felt very close to her walter
badgett a victorian writer and one of
the greatest editors of the economist
said that the thing about monarchy is it
brings sovereignty down to the level of
everyday life and that's what she did we
felt we knew her so it's it's not
surprising that it feels strange
that she has gone monarchy you know is
the ultimate elitist institution rooted
in in the privilege of birth
and we're in this environment where
elites are out but somehow under queen
elizabeth the british monarchy has been
a product of fascination for everybody
around the world this is a lot to do
with queen elizabeth herself there's no
doubt that changes of monarchy are
destabilizing times for countries
and they always have been when henry vii
died his courteous was so worried that
this would fatally destabilize the tudor
dynasty that they hid his body in his
rooms for two days and continued to
bring his
corpse meals as though it were alive and
even in the era of victoria when
victoria died the novelist henry james
said we all feel motherless today
so this is an unnerving time and i think
because of the length of her reign and
also because of who she is it feels
particularly unloving for britain it
felt like
she epitomized a certain sort of
britishness
that britain liked about itself she was
stoical she worked hard she kept her
emotions under her hats
in a way that is
starting to feel like something that was
from the past it feels like
she has in going something that tethered
us to an era
of our history that britain was proud of
has also gone someone said to me in the
past week and i it was a very striking
thing they said when everybody
around the world descends on london for
queen elizabeth's funeral
it will be the last time the dozens of
heads of state descend on london
and i wonder whether that's true um i
think it certainly is the the passing of
the monarch who has presided over
a period of britain's growing
diminishment on the global stage and it
sort of feels that
this marks a moment where we are now
becoming the mid-sized country we really
are but it is an institution that will
endure in a very practical sense it
matters that there's a new monarch on
the british throne because
of the commonwealth so the monarch is
also head of the commonwealth and
it's an enormous institution two and a
half billion people 56 countries and the
queen was the head of it and she loved
it and she spent an enormous amount of
time working to keep it together uh
prime minister of new zealand said once
that she was the glue that kept it all
together for a long time they've been
worried that without the queen at the
helm that the whole thing will start to
if not holy come apart then the bonds
between it will start to weaken there
will be concerns about the future of the
monarchy as there always are at the
beginning of every new reign people will
feel that charles iii does not have the
stature
and indeed approach of his mother but at
the same time i think the monarchy plays
an incredibly important role in britain
there's been much talk about king
charles wanting to slim down the royal
family i think there'll be a lot of talk
about that but there won't be very much
action and probably nothing much will
happen for a while so it will take some
time for king charles to be crowned king
and thereafter his will be a much
shorter reign than his mother's and then
there is the next generation and i think
he is in a position where the excitement
will be with the next generation but i
suspect that the fascination around the
world with this family
and
the role that the constitutional
monarchy plays in the uk
is not going anywhere
charles's greatest challenge is that we
know him far too well the coronery of
the longest reigning monarch is the
longest draining heir apparent and while
he has been heir apparent we've all had
a very good chance to have a very good
look at him so we know about his
disastrous marriage to diana we know
about his affair with kavina parker
bowles who is now his consort and we
know about his own passions and his
interests and also that he has pressed
those passions and interests a little
bit more than most people feel is
correct for a
uh royal in a constitutional monarchy
so charles's difficulty will be to show
that the things that people fear about
him are not going to be there in his
reign i speak to you and it was striking
he gave his first public speech as
monarch the day after his mother died
throughout her life her majesty the
queen
my beloved mother
was an inspiration
an example to me
and to all my family it was very notable
that in his speech he came not only to
praise his mother
but also to bury some of the criticisms
that have been leveled at him over the
years so he used the word duty
four times in his speech he used the
word example three times twice in his
first paragraph so he was sending a
clear message he was saying she is going
to be my model so far the british public
seemed to be
mellowing towards him so his his yougov
ratings showed that those who think that
he was going to do a good job had risen
from 32
to almost double that 63 in just a week
however within less than seven days of
his reign starting he was seen to have
what looked almost like a little temper
tantrum because his ink pen stopped
working
i think the public mood could quite
quickly dip if we see too much more of
that from him
you're right too much light let in on
magic could show a character that may
not be as appealing as his mother yeah i
i think there is a real danger of that
and and if he can't even hold it
together for a full week um
it will be interesting to see how he
behaves in the coming years even decades
to read more of the economist's coverage
on the death of queen elizabeth ii click
the link
thank you for watching